what's going on everybody welcome to the
third Python in Flast practical tutorial
video in this video we're going to be
talking about building our kind of
homepage using bootstrap and stuff like
that so let's go ahead and get started
so bringing winscp over here when you
first log in to win SCP this is probably
what you'll see just this is the
directory for your root user but we
actually want to go to the root
directory which is all the way back here
then to find your actual files for flask
you saved them in bar www flask app and
then that's where we made the WSGI you
probably not really changed anything
there but then here's where the the main
bits of our our flask app begin this is
our init dot pi file and you'll see that
when we double click that this comes up
and this is that file that we created
initially and we created it via SSH now
normally when you double click on a file
these file Wynn asset Wynn SCP it'll
come up I don't know probably buy a
notepad plus plus if that if you have
that installed otherwise notepad now
that's kind of annoying
what your Python files that come up with
a Python editor so to do that in winscp
although in really any of these file
transferring applications you should be
able to change the editor so you might
want to figure out how to do that but
anyways for us we'll go to options
preferences come on down to editors and
in here basically mask is the file
extension and in the you basically write
these in the order that you want them to
check so the very first one is idle
anything that ends in dot pi try to open
with idle otherwise everything else open
with notepad plus plus so basically
you're going to you're in a lot you know
modify to major types of file types
that's going to be dot HTML and dot PI
but you'll also you might be editing
JavaScript or CSS or whatever and
everything will open a notepad plus plus
basically except for dot PI files so I'm
going to close out of this now and so
yeah now when I open up in it
I it's obviously in in Python now I'm
also going to make the font size here
just the bigger okay
so now what do we want to do well first
we mentioned that we're going to be
using bootstraps so we know we want to
go there but first let's go ahead and
get started with with some templates so
we're going to come into templates
before we go any explaining a little bit
I actually this video don't worry but
we'll get to that
so first let's go into templates and
there's nothing here templates is where
we're going to put all of our HTML files
so I right click new and now I'm going
to call this main HTML that brings up
this main file here this down and this
will be our kind of like our if you're
familiar with old-school kind of
paradigms this will be kind of like a
header file only now the header file
contains both the header and the footer
and you don't really have to have like
top and bottom don't worry about it if
you don't know but it can be kind of
confusing if you're coming from
traditional PHP kind of styled paradigms
so this is our main file and now we're
ready to build in HTML file so again a
lot of HTML is simply copy and paste so
for example we can come over to
bootstrap and let's just view the source
so to view a source of a website you can
right click view source view page source
or if you're in chrome you can do
control U and so on so you see here they
have all this stuff and it's contained
uh at least all of this is contained
within a pretty large head actually we
don't really want to do all of that but
basically all websites start with the
following they've got dot type and then
HTML and then they begin with this head
tag again you don't need to know a lot
of HTML but I hope that you understand
the basics of tags and all this stuff
but you see they start with this head
some meta stuff blah blah blah blah blah
some of this stuff here meta names and
stuff like that so basically we want to
do the same thing so let's just copy
that at least those first three lines we
want those this just identifies this
type as HTML this identifies the HTML
languages
English we begin the head will go ahead
and close the head now and now we're
going to put some stuff within the
header tags now generally I don't really
see too many people indent the head even
though the head is within HTML and in
fact let's close off our HTML tags as
well I never really see people in dense
but it since you're we're all Python
folk you do want to maintain some degree
of standards so Python automatically
indents you know blocks of code for you
HTML doesn't you could actually code
HTML all on one line so you could do
something like this and have like all of
your HTML code on literate lips not
deleted but all on one line you you
that's totally fine
but it's just bad standards so you don't
want to do that in early Genet general
generally anyways generally what you'll
want to do is you'll want to indent over
stuff that's contained generally again
people want to do it between the HTML
tags but everything else they do so now
we're going to do the same do that car
set so come back over here I'm sure that
yeah they defined car set so we'll just
copy that tab paste basically this
defines the encoding for your web page
it's utf-8 enter and now we're ready to
put some more stuff next thing is the
page title so this would just be you
know what's the title of your page
basically in a no Pierre in the tab you
know up here and we're going to call
this a Python programming tutorials this
over here um and so that's our title
easy enough let's see if they did the
viewport they sure did we'll copy their
viewport as well let me zoom in this one
as well so this is the viewport
basically let's just let's copy that
first viewport is kind of its code
specifically for your browser really all
of this is HTML is interpreted by
everyone's browser that's why HTML is so
universal
and it works on everything you know and
that's why websites in general are very
universal because they're actually just
interet they at the end of the day they
spit out HTML that's interpreted by
browsers on all the operating systems so
it's actually a really nice system I
think anyways this is some browser code
basically
it it encourages the browser to use the
full size of the browser okay so the
idea of bootstrap is that it's very
responsive and it works on multiple
screens so that's obviously something we
want so next we've got the viewport and
now you're generally going to see CSS
sheets so let's see if they've got a CSS
sheet anywhere that we can copy and
paste I'm not here we go here's one so
let's just say that this is this is a
style sheet this is how you link to a
style sheet so basically the link href
is the reference to where is that style
sheets stored and then you tell the
browser hey by the way this is a style
sheet so we're going to do the same
thing and our style sheet is actually
going to be called bootstrap mint CSS
but with flask in traditional again PHP
everything is stored and visited via the
URL path identically so the URL path to
a file is exactly the path to the file
on the server sometimes it's a local
path though like if you're using shared
hosting or VPS is generally shared - but
it's it's the same path right with flask
not the case so say you're on a like a
web site or you're on a web page that is
like the following let's say Python
programming dotnet slash home slash test
and you told the browser that the
stylesheet is located in let's say a
static slash bootstrap dot CSS let's say
it's going to look for this file at the
following location it's going to look
for it here and with us it's not going
to find it there because that's not
where the file is so flask has a nice
way to dynamically link to files and
here's how it works you use the phrase
URL for and it's a variable and the way
that we define variables in flask is
with these double curly braces
this is variable you also have logic and
logic is defined with the curly brace
and then the percent sign and this is
logic and anytime you have logic you
need to also have and logic because this
is the templating code so again coming
from Python it's a very unfamiliar thing
when you have to close off things like
you know if start and end and and that's
just not something that is done in
Python but we here this is actually
called Jinja templating and it's
required with Jinja templating you do
not need an end far though so anyway
that's logic so we're going to use of
logic and variables so we're going to
use a variable code and the variable
code is going to be a variable that is
the result of this URL underscore 4
which is a flask function and it's is
going to be URL 4 and then for what
where is this item that we're looking
for
well it's within a static directory and
then you'll do a comma and then you'll
say what fought what's the file name
within the static directory and for us
we're static is the only directory
that's like directly accessible by the
user so I'll show you that hopefully in
a little bit we don't have anything in
static right now so I can't show it to
you right now but that's the only
directory where people will be able to
access it because they'll be able to go
to Python programming dotnet slash
static and they'll find your stuff and
in fact I can't show you because I can
show you on Python programming net so
let's do here paste and you can see all
the stuff that's contained in Python
programming net dot slash static but we
also there is also templates right
templates just in the same directory as
static so could we do templates to see
all of Python program Nets templates no
we can't we get a 404 error with this
lovely snake I've drawn so anyways huh
so just so you know static is the only
directory viewable but you don't
necessary
well nevermind anyways we're going to
get out of that uh so static and then
within static we're gonna have a bunch
of different files so we did here as
well so you'll see since this is the
website we're building within CSS or I'm
sorry within static we have different
things because CSS documents downloads
basically everything you want that user
to be able to access directly not just
the server access but the user isn't
static if you want something hosted
privately you push it somewhere else and
then you temporarily send it to the
browser and there's all kinds of fancy
things you can do but static is for
public stuff so again in static we've
got the CSS directory which stores CSS
we also have a js4 JavaScript videos
images just all kinds of stuff in here
so anyways we want to have CSS and
that's where we're going to store all of
our CSS stuff so coming back over here
so the URL for the static directory and
within the static directory we're
looking for the file name equal to CSS
because it'll be the CSS directory
forward slash bootstrap min dot CSS
that's what we're looking for okay so
next actually let me just fullscreen
this no no sense and uh leaving the
other stuff on the screen so anyways
that's our CSS sheet and then now we
just have one more thing we want a
reference and that's going to be our our
shortcut icon so that's the icon that
appears sent as soon as I is right here
right it's your fav icons what it's
generally called so we want to reference
that as well so we're going to say link
and we're going to say relation is a
shortcut icon and H ref is equal and
again we're going to use basically the
same thing so I'm going to copy and
paste this URL for here paste and it's
in static it's not in its own directory
and it is going to be called fav icon I
scoops favicon dot ICO we'll save that
but of course bootstrap Minn dot CSS and
fav icon just don't exist yet so we need
to create those so I'm going to move
this over now
and we're going to deal with getting
those icons and the bootstrap stuff so
for Python programming specific files
and stuff really no reason for me to
provide them to you and like a directory
or something that you can download they
are all available on Python programming
net so for example we do need the fav
icon so we'll come here and we'll take
this fav icon here let me just drag and
drop it to the desktop I suppose last
time I did this yeah converted it to a
PNG I don't know why it's doing this let
me save it
let's try saving it yeah so it saves as
a fit favicon dot ICO but if I take it
from the debtor from here to my desktop
it just does not want to be you know
good so anyway um oh no absolutely
we still disconnected from I guess it
was too long for it to hold for me
that's okay anyway downloads and there's
my fav icon so now come to winscp I'll
go into the directory which was static
just flat static and I'm going to click
and drag this fav icon over so we've at
least done that and now we need to get
bootstrap so let's go ahead and grab a
bootstrap or some stuff over so here's
my download directory just fav icon in
there and then we're going to come to
bootstrap here and we just want to
download bootstrap we don't want the
source code we want just bootstrap
that's a you need a compiler to use that
and stuff so once you have bootstrap you
get this will right click extract all
extract and now we've got bootstrap dist
and then in here you've got CSS fonts
and JavaScript so CSS is the style
sheets that we're going to use fonts
things like glyph icons which we are
going to use and then JavaScript so now
again we click and drag and we're going
to click and drag that into the static
directory so do that and it might take a
little bit shouldn't be too long these
files aren't really huge and then once
that's done we should have everything
we'll go ahead and refresh just to make
sure uh main dot HTML did we actually
save our main
yeah we did let me minimize this let's
come over here and let's refresh you see
that oh okay right there's one more
thing well there's a couple more things
we needed to do um man I'm really bummed
I got to reload this thing me alright
once we've made it this far so I had to
restart this and now it's telling me I
need a system restart
I'm sure it's telling you guys the same
thing so at the end of this series or at
the end of this tutorial rather run a
pseudo reboot if I forget to tell you so
it should be totally fine to continue on
at least for now but it might cause
trouble later so don't forget to do a
reboot if you need it let's see okay so
flask app we've got our templates main
dot HTML now we need to actually call
upon main dot HTML so we go into flask
app and we're going to open up in it by
and for now
we see that right now home page just
returns
hi there how you doing now we're going
to talk about how do we have it return a
template so what we're going to do is
from flask import flask comma render
underscore template whoa at a space
there just to be clean and what render
template does is exactly what sounds
like renders a template so instead of
returning a string we return render
underscore template and now you give the
path to the template starting from the
template directory so in our case we go
into template directory and we see it's
just straight main dot HTML so the path
is main data HTML but if you could and
you can and we will or at least I do I'm
pretty sure I can at least show you how
I've done it so there'll be more
directories in here and you'll have
various meanings for these directories
and names and stuff and then say you had
another directory that was like I don't
know footer you might have something
like this footer slash main HTML and
that would be acceptable as well so
anyways we'll save that and once we've
done that anytime you make a change to
the init dot pi or any of the Python
files whoops I didn't mean to click on
that link you need to issue a service
Apache to restart so we'll restart
Apache you might get something
this it does not matter well come over
here refresh and at least we see our fav
icon works we don't see anything else
but we can view the source and we see
all this stuff and remember that here's
our main HTML right this was a variable
right it was a variable to our static
style sheets but we come over here and
we see it's actually given you know the
relative path basically to it we can
click it and we can see that yep indeed
we are actually getting there cool I
think that's really cool I love the idea
of variables in the HTML and then we can
even do logic that's just awesome so
anyway the next thing we can we can do
though just to show you it works is we
can add some paragraph tags really quick
and say like hi there how you doing save
that we've modified the HTML do we need
to restart Apache no refresh hi there
how you doing pretty cool and you might
even notice that the font is different
and the reason the font is different is
because we've loaded in our stylesheet
so because of bootstrap we already have
a better-looking font and that's really
it this is 20 minutes so we'll cut that
off now and then we'll continue on
making our homepage and stuff in the
next video if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until the next video